foreign
welcome to another installment of Harry
Potter theory in today's video we're
going to be discussing Muggles Wizards
and Magic however we're going to go a
little off course from the usual style
of video as we will not only be
discussing the existence of magic in the
Harry Potter universe but including the
Lord of the Rings universe as well in
addition to identifying the key
differences for what constitutes magic
in both worlds I'm going to try to
attempt to identify which World of Magic
is more powerful for years decades we've
known about both of these universes and
we've accepted them both for what they
are but what I want to do today is put
them head to head and answer the
question once and for all who's more
powerful Harry Potter Wizards or Lord of
the Rings Wizards the first thing that I
want to say is that both Harry Potter
and Lord of the Rings are behemoths in
media they've each cultivated some of
the biggest followings and have
established their own unique devoted fan
bases around to both
films while they are certainly rivals in
the space they definitely share a mutual
audience and though they are both in the
realm of fantasy they're more than
different enough to harmoniously coexist
one thing is for certain though and
that's the fact that Lord of the Rings
has been around for longer much longer
in fact Tolkien published the first
installment of Lord of the Rings The
Fellowship of the Ring in 1954. the next
two books were published in the 15
months that followed the Fellowship of
the Ring movie however took a
Blasphemous 47 years to come out as it
wasn't released until 2001.
coincidentally 2001 was also the year
that the first Harry Potter film came
out Harry Potter and the Philosopher's
Stone which had only been published in
book form four years earlier 2001 was a
great year for Cinema two of the most
popular novels had suddenly come to the
big screen and all at once I went to go
see both films in theaters when they
came out though I was only 9 years old
and I'll outwardly state that I have a
preference for Harry Potter
the Harry Potter YouTube channel I was
enthralled by the different worlds of
magic placed before me each approaching
the concept of a fantasy world in their
own unique way the first Harry Potter
was quite innocent and childlike as the
characters were still young and the
story had yet to develop however they
certainly nailed the sense of magic that
they were going for as the Hogwarts boat
scene brings forth a level of nostalgia
and paralleled to this day the darker
tone that the film developed as they
progressed fit the story perfectly and
eased us into the darker side of magic
similarly the first Lord of the Rings
graced our screens with what can only be
described as a grandiose cinematic
experience giving us a different flavor
of magical world but aside from the
different music scenery and overall
aesthetic how does magic differ from
franchise to franchise to identify these
differences we need to look the origins
of magic in each franchise in the Harry
Potter Universe witches Wizards are
essentially Advanced or mutated human
beings they have advanced physiologies
heightened perception option and if
trained enough have ability to control
the world's elements to some extent
basically witches and wizards are just
enhanced humans which means that their
existence pre-magic is the same as the
original ancestors of humans who were
thought to have first existed about 6
million years ago over millions of years
humans developed and evolved and so it
shouldn't be surprising to anyone that
eventually humans started showing
Supernatural capabilities the ability to
perform magic though the origins of
wizard kind in Harry Potter are
undefined we do have some information
about the first known magical being the
first known wizard across all continents
was a wizard by the name of jejaminik
who hailed from Egypt as far back as
2600 BC there is little to no
information available on jejamanek other
than where he was from and the period in
which he lived but I do wonder if wizard
kind went back further than that or if
he was truly the first the origins of
magic are still unclear to this day no
one knows whether the Inception of
wizard kind was born from humans
randomly discovering them magical
abilities or if it was created in some
form by way of pact ritual or potion I'm
personally of the impression that a
discovery of magic was a genetic
mutation or perhaps the next logical
step in human evolution either way
witches and wizards are humans this is
where things differ from Lord of the
Rings in a big way but before we get
into that let's just wrap up magic in
Harry Potter by seeing how JK Rowling
envisions the concept of magic in the
Harry Potter Universe magic is a
supernatural force that changes aspects
of the world at fundamental levels the
ability for humans to use magic is a
hereditary trait passed down from a
person's ancestors which allows witches
and wizards to practice it rather than
being a mystical or unnatural Pursuit
that defied the laws of nature however
magic simply allowed those who could
wield it to exploit them in very
specific and creative ways that muggle
Sciences were unable to replicate
different species in Harry Potter like
goblins and elves seem to use this same
magic and there are no apparent
different in the type of magic that they
perform all magical forms of life in
Harry Potter simply possess the ability
to wield magic and it's not necessarily
that they themselves are magical only
that they are able to take advantage of
the magic around them witches and
wizards in Harry Potter have the magic
Gene but the difference here is that the
Wizards and all of the rings represent
the elements themselves they are the
forces of nature personified like Harry
Potter there are many types of magical
beings in Lord of the Rings Elves
dwarves ants and even humans the
difference here however is that each of
these magical creatures has their own
brand and level of magic some humans are
able to perform basic levels of magic
like Aragorn and his healing but most of
them can't and those who can most likely
learn their abilities from the elves
Elven kind are among the most powerful
of the magical beings and seem to be
able to do things like Forge magical
artifacts manipulate nature Etc the
witches and wizards of the Harry Potter
Universe besides possessing the magical
Gene have some other notable theological
benefits that make them Advanced humans
these traits include longer lifespans
though not to a significant extent and a
resistance to most common illnesses Lord
of the Rings is on another level
altogether here because believe it or
not the bodies of elves live
indefinitely in Middle Earth they can be
killed or so badly injured that their
Spirits forsake their bodies but if left
alone they will live forever the only
Immortals in the Harry Potter Universe
are phoenixes which are destined to
undergo the same death birth cycle for
their entire existence largely
superseding all of the aforementioned
creatures in both universes however are
the Wizards of Lord of the Rings the
Mayar unlike Harry Potter the Wizards of
The Lord of the Rings series are not
humans at all in fact they are basically
Angels created by the god eru the one to
be divine beings there were at least 15
likely more created by eru and at one
point five of the Maya living in valinor
the land where all gods live gave up
their angel form to become human
in order to live in Arda Middle Earth
and help the other creations humans
elves dwarfs Etc two blue Wizards went
East to live with humans radagast the
Brown went to the woods to help animal
life Gandalf the Gray traveled all over
helping those who needed it and Saruman
the white the denizing guard to lead the
white Council here's the truth and it's
a tough pill to swallow because I'm
obviously a huge Harry Potter fan the
Magic exhibited in Lord of the Rings is
far more powerful than the Magic in
Harry Potter the witches and wizards of
Harry Potter are more comparable to the
elves of Lord of the Rings than the
Wizards and that's not because Harry
Potter magic isn't powerful but it's
because Maya are Divine beings Maya are
the forces of nature they are the
onlookers of Earth its inhabitants and
all of the elements that exist take
Gandalf for example who is often
compared to Dumbledore though Dumbledore
is unequivocally wise Gandalf is
basically omniscient he has knowledge of
all intelligent life forms on the planet
and is responsible for communication in
with all of them to defeat evil Sauron
another Mayar has the power to create
life trolls ogres Orcs And radagast can
control all animals these Wizards
possess power and paralleled by a Harry
Potter equivalent and while Dumbledore
Voldemort's Grindelwald are about as
close as you're going to get they are
still nothing to the Maya the Maya and
body magic they don't just Channel it
and they possess the ability to control
influence people with their words alone
the best example of powerful magic
displayed in Harry Potter is probably
the duel between Voldemort and
Dumbledore in the ministry Atrium and to
put things into perspective elves and
Lord of the Rings who also possess the
ability to control the elements could
have put on a comparable battle at the
end of the day however each franchise
just approaches the concept of magic in
their own unique way magic in Lord of
the Rings seems to have more Dimensions
to it and is viewed in a sort of
spiritual context magic in Harry Potter
has more of a utilitarian feel and is
more about using magic to help overcome
the problem or obstacles in front of you
whichever way you look at it both
universes did a great job at
establishing their own unique approach
to World of Magic what do you guys think
did you ever wonder which World of Magic
was more powerful let me know in the
comment section below until next time
remember time will not slow down when
something unpleasant lies ahead